et ce rendez vous avec l'élection
présidentielle il est désormais
quotidiens avec vous au schoren verdure
bonjour lensois raphael est aujourd'hui
bien c'est la question corse qui a fait
irruption dans la campagne
présidentielle oui le gouvernement
français se dit prêt à aller jusqu'à
l'autonomie pour lille une première qui
a suscité une cascade de réactions parmi
les candidats cette déclaration sur
l'autonomie émane du ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin en visite
aujourd'hui demain sur l'île de beauté
elle intervient après la violente
agression en prison d' yvan colonna
condamné pour l'assassinât du préfet
erignac en 1998 et après les
manifestations de soutien aux militants
indépendantistes qui ont suivi notamment
celle de dimanche dernier qui a donné
lieu à des affrontements faisant des
dizaines de blessés le récap politique
est signée florent au dos et nicolas
ouvert
c'est l'histoire de la fin d'un tabou
grande première l'exécutif dit envisager
l'autonomie de la corse dans le
brouillard depuis l'agression divan
colonna en prison début mars
de la politique émotion pour les rivaux
des manuels macron
[Musique]
ce qui est terrible c'est qu'il faut un
drame comme d'habitude avec ce
quinquennat pour commencer à entrevoir
des solutions jamais rien n'est anticipé
cette crise comme les autres pas gérer
pas gérer du tout un peu plus de 10
jours avant que le ministre de
l'intérieur où un ministre tout
simplement du gouvernement ne se rende
encore ce qu on a un président qui
visiblement aux abois aux abois et
qu'ils cèdent à la violence il faut
ramener l'ordre en corse avant d'entamer
les négociations
une île de beauté un jour autonome eric
zemmour marine le pen et nicolas
dupont-aignan sont contre pour philippe
poutou si la démocratie est bafouée en
corse la légitimité de cette élection
les biens plus pique adressée aux médias
qui le considèrerait comme un candidat
de seconde zone
on va pas décourager au contraire on va
s'accrocher alors gens là ça y est il y
avait peut-être en train de craquer mais
nous on se dit que ben on va rester et
puis si on peut faire si on va faire
chier non lâche pas le truc lui le truc
justement il a bien failli le lâcher car
la première chaîne d'information de
france
vaut méprise ce point
et bien moi ça me donne avait eu peggle
nausées ou pas jean lassalle poursuit
son bonhomme de chemin trois jours de
visite à mayotte et à la réunion
destinations moins exotiques pour fabien
roussel la région parisienne où le
communiste et rouge de colère contre
emmanuel macron pas contre sa promesse
d'augmenter le point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires mais contre le timing
ils sont incroyables cela il faudrait
faire des élections présidentielles tous
les 6 mois parce que comme ça on verra
peut-être les salaires et les retraites
augmenter aussi faire ça quand même à 25
jours du premier tour c'est un peu
gonflé gonflé il est plaqué au sol ce
jeune homme vient d'aspergés valérie
pécresse de poudre
c'est passé elle voit désormais la vie
en rose mais pas exactement comme elles
l'avaient imaginé
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
on en a beaucoup parlé ces dernières
semaines h rennes sur notre antenne l
invasion russe de l'ukraine a fortement
perturbé cette campagne oui donnant au
président macron un avantage certain il
a été porté par son activisme
diplomatique pour tenter de mettre fin à
cette crise et contraignant donc les
autres candidats à se positionner elle
tend sur la guerre elle-même que sur ses
conséquences certains d'ailleurs
notamment à l'extrême droite pâtissent
aujourd'hui de leur complaisance ou même
de leur sympathie passé vis-à-vis de
moscou est difficile maintenant pour eux
de rectifier le tir on en parle ce soir
avec notre chroniqueuse international
virginie hertz bonsoir virginie merci de
nous avoir rejoints tout d'abord comment
est ce que les différents candidats à la
présidentielle interprète cette guerre
alors tous condamne l'agression russe
mais il ya beaucoup de nuances en tout
cas il ya une claire démarcation entre
ceux qui estiment qu'au-delà de
l'ukraine la russie attaque la
démocratie et les valeurs démocratiques
et les autres disons plus neutre qui met
en valeur la responsabilité de
l'occident et de l'otan en particulier
c'est le cas à gauche particulièrement
de nathalie arthaud qu'on écoute
je pense que le camp occidental
l'impérialisme américain derrière l'otan
a une responsabilité écrasante vous
savez on est là on a affaire à une
guerre entre brigands alors moi je suis
contre justement cet ordre impérialistes
brigands ce règne de brigands voilà une
guerre entre briguant la candidate de
lutte ouvrière qui espère que les
travailleurs russes vont réussir à
arrêter la guerre estime que faire
passer le camp occidental impérialistes
pour la blanche colombe qui va venir
sauver les peuples alors qu'ils ont été
au coeur du problème c'est se tromper
cruellement et c'est une analyse qui est
partagé en fait très largement par jean
luc mélenchon le candidat de la france
insoumise qui est très critiquée par ses
adversaires de gauche pour son non
alignement qui masque une complaisance
avec moscou et pour son esprit munichois
en référence aux accords de munich
signés en 1938 qui ont mené au
démembrement de la tchécoslovaquie
sous prétexte de sauver la paix à gauche
pour le reste pour yannick jadot en
particulier philippe poutou fabien
roussel dans une moindre mesure mais
aussi et anne hidalgo dans cette guerre
il n'y a pas de neutralité écoutez anne
hidalgo
là c'est un combat qui est très clair
c'est d'un côté d une dictature et de
l'autre côté des démocraties il n'y a
pas de troisième voie il n'y a pas de
non alignement le choix doit être clair
voilà et à droite c'est aussi le point
de vue de valérie pécresse qui estime
que vladimir poutine est l'ennemi de la
france parce qu'il a violé les règles
internationales du droit international
la candidate des républicains qui ne
s'est pas privé de critiquer à plusieurs
reprises la poutine ofili passer de ses
adversaires de droite marine le pen et
eric zemmour et eric zemmour lui qui est
très embarrassé par ce conflit un
conflit qui est totalement hors sujet
par rapport à ses principales
préoccupations à lui on écoute ça nous
distrait du vrai choc de civilisations
l'affrontement entre les frères russes
et ukrainiens
doit se régler comme tout affrontement
sera ternel et européens nos problèmes
fondamentaux sont au sud ils ne sont pas
à l'est voilà pour le diagnostic hagrid
analyse un des principaux candidats donc
que propose-t-il pour sortir de la crise
virginie alors il ya une unanimité sur
la solution diplomatique que ce soit par
pacifisme ou par réalisme c'est une
position qui peut être résumée par
nicolas dupont aignan qui je le cite dit
nous devons trouver un compromis car
vladimir poutine ou pas la russie
restera selon le candidat de la france
debout il faut traiter le problème à la
racine et ne pas laisser je le cite deux
plaies purulentes au coeur de l'europe
alors si tous les candidats s'accordent
sur la nécessité de négocier avec moscou
en revanche ils sont très divisés sur
les sanctions économiques et la
livraison d'armes à l'ukraine et leurs
électeurs aussi d'ailleurs un sondage du
journal du dimanche il ya sept jours a
montré qu'une majorité de français
étaient en faveur de la livraison
d'armes à l'ukraine 62% mais c'est ou
non à 70 % ce sont des électeurs verts
qui sont en faveur de la livraison
d'armes à leurs hôtes enfin voilà une
rupture claire avec le pacifisme
traditionnel des verts en revanche les
électeurs les plus ré disant oseo
livraison d'un pardon son genre les
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon et de
marine le pen dans les deux cas ces deux
candidats aussi sont contre des
sanctions économiques car pour jean luc
mélenchon elles sont inefficaces et une
seat notamment l'iran et cuba comme
exemple estimant que les russes
produiront eux mêmes leurs biens et
qu'ils deviendront de toute façon
autonome quant à marine le pen elle elle
craint surtout une forte augmentation
des prix edit cause qu'il importe ce qui
nous importe surtout c'est la france
alors comment résoudre cette guerre tous
plus ou moins propose de faire des
grandes conférences internationales que
ce soit avec l'onu l'ouest et l'union
européenne
quant à emmanuel macron mis aujourd'hui
qui en position de chef de guerre et
vous avez dit et qui est favorisée
finalement par cette situation il a
déclaré aujourd'hui qu'il n'excluait pas
d'aller à kiev ou à moscou peut-être pas
dans les prochains jours mais
prochainement il faut dire que pour
l'instant quand même ces initiatives
diplomatiques n'ont pas beaucoup abouti
merci beaucoup virginie et donc on vous
retrouvera désormais chaque semaine dans
france 2022 lors du choix pour donc
analyser une question internationale en
lien avec la campagne présidentielle
ainsi l'ukraine a tout écrasé à 1 comme
on dira à 25 jours du premier tour y a
quand même nécessité pour les candidats
d'aller sur le terrain de faire campagne
de convaincre les électeurs et ça passe
parfois par ce qu'on appelle les petites
phrases oui petite phrase slogan
expression qui ont marqué les esprits on
parler aux français et ont parfois
changé raphaël le cours de l'histoire
avec une victoire à la clé retour à
présent sur ces mots bien pensé associer
à certaines campagnes présidentielles du
passé avec des fuites imbert et
jean-marie lequertier
leur programme leur personnalité le
contexte politique le rejet de
l'adversaire
bien des facteurs expliquent une
victoire à la présidentielle mais il ya
aussi la phrase l'expression bien
choisies au bon moment celle qui
s'imprime dans la tête des électeurs
ils font tous distille pour éviter une
fracture sociale comme si celle ci
n'existait pas déjà la fracture sociale
jacques chirac qui la met au coeur de sa
campagne réussie en 1995 après deux
échecs à conquérir l'elysée quand chirac
trouve la fracture sociale c'est
intéressant ce que chirac a déjà une
base populaire il est clairement
identifiée à droite il a tout se passait
de droite donc il se permet de faire ce
qu'on appelle trianguler c'est à dire il
va sortir une phrase de gauche pour
faire mouche une formule doit donc
parler à l'électorat le plus large
possible nicolas sarkozy l'a trouve en
2006 huit mois avant son élection il
faut laisser dans le privé comme dans le
public
ceux qui veulent travailler plus pour
gagner plus le faire l'objectif était de
faire simple racontent les témoins de
cette campagne est de cette trouvaille
c'étaient des mots du langage quotidien
travailler plus gagner plus
abolir purement et simplement les 35
heures et c'était un
chiffon rouge qui allait mettre le feu
il fallait le faire plus intelligemment
la force tranquille de françois
mitterrand le bon choix de valéry
giscard d'estaing ou encore je voudrais
regarder la france au fond des yeux les
slogans et les propos sont ciselés
formaté pensée pour séduire les
électeurs mais vous dire que mon
adversaire cet adversaire c'est le monde
de la finance quitte à provoquer des
lendemains qui déchantent ceux qui
pensent ne pas gagner peuvent toujours
faire toutes les formules qui veulent ça
ne va pas avoir beaucoup d'impact
ensuite fin quand on gagne après on
assume la responsabilité de la gestion
d'un pays c'est vrai que pour ce qui est
de la finance est mon ennemi ya eu des
choses qui ont été faites mais qui n'ont
pas été perçus comme étant à la hauteur
de la forme d'une une simple phrase peut
donc aider à gagner une élection
al'inverse le projet que je propose au
pays ce pas un projet socialiste elle
peut coller à la peau d'un candidat et
contribué à l'échec mon programme n'est
pas socialiste ils se coupent
instantanément des électeurs de gauche
il devient incohérent comprend plus sa
position il n'ya pas pire pour un homme
politique que de perdre au fond sa
boussole ce qu'il représente le
symbolise auprès des électeurs
il n'y a donc pas de recette miracle en
2017 j'ai choisi en même temps le en
même temps des manuels macro
avait connu un certain succès 2022
attend encore son tube de campagne
et pour conclure comme chaque soir notre
archive du joug en écho à l'actualité
justement concernant la corse oui une
archive de françois mitterrand élu en
mai 81 premier chef d'état de gauche de
la vème république une nouveauté qui
avait suscité beaucoup d'espoir sur
l'île de beauté alors que le milieu des
années soixante dix avaient vu l'essor
du nationalisme sur l'île moins d'un an
après son accession au pouvoir la corse
se voit dotée d'un statut différent de
celui des autres régions et aussi d'une
assemblée mais plus d'autonomie ne
voulait pas dire encouragement à la
sécession écouter la vision du président
mitterrand une archive du 10 septembre
1993 c'était à bastia
corse les amis soyez donc vous même
et apporter à la france
qui nous est commune
ce que lui doivent tous ses fils
que feriez-vous sans nous que ferions
nous sans vous
vive bastia
vivez la corse
vive la république fait de la france
et c'est tout pour ce soir fait merci h
rennes on vous retrouve demain pour
france 2022 l'heure du choix notre
chronique quotidienne de la campagne
présidentielle ici en france reste avec
nous au prochain journal dans trois
minutes dans paris diagne